[Music]
new cockerel new mm-hmm
deformation slap submitted by to brute a
it - where's that from
Brutus Caesar yes Caesar god you're so
uneducated I only know that because my
[ __ ] what to call my junior high
[ __ ] history teacher said that [ __ ]
all the time
I don't know it's usually a high school
that our church though I was cool and I
ditched you go [ __ ] education did tell
it to Isaac a 12 year old journalist
faces off with a police officer who
threatened to arrest her oh [ __ ]
she must be white to face off with the
[ __ ] uh wait she's a she's a 12 year
old journalist yeah she intelligent
that's [ __ ] cute dude I just picture
her with a clipboard like that she's
intelligent she was able to articulate
and defend herself or just get her ass
beat by the cop it had to be tied did it
on another type but then it'd be funny
like a sketchy no Hildy this might sting
little [ __ ] she the Orange Street news
and she's been the editor since she was
nine years old she started this I said
her own publication I know what is that
so her dad is a reporter the journalist
that's where she got it from so she
would go with her dad and like go check
out stories or whatever yeah and so she
really that she really likes that she
wants to do her own newspaper and so her
dad was like all right you write all the
stories and I'll fix up the website and
then she was just three years of
experience mm-hmm and then or was it six
yes six judgments there's skill when
kids want to follow in their parents
footsteps and they actually do it yeah
yeah they're actually passionate about
it yeah she's gotten threats from drug
dealers cuz of a story that she followed
and girl that reminds me of like when a
I used to live in a bad neighborhood the
neighbor who lived across the street
from me got raided by the FBI and then
you know James Brown I think he's on or
not James Brown Jim wait what's this
the guy with the big mustache the black
dude with the big mustache he's a he's a
news anchor Judge Joe Brown something
news anchor yeah you know you know who
I'm talkin a Ms Brown I think though but
you guys know what I'm talking about
yeah that's kind of cute right like a
little round nose yeah yeah yeah he's
the one who had that meme where it's
like you know murder on the loose and it
looks attack this guy came to is it Cal
or some [ __ ] I don't know he came to our
house knocked on the door and then you
know and I opened it and he was like
yeah so I just wanted to get a quick
interview about you know what had
happened my mom said close it we're in
saying [ __ ]
she's like close the door close the door
I said sorry in fact doesn't door
because she's like you know what if
these guys are watching the news and
then you say something you know nothing
about and you say something wrong and it
offends them right so yeah same [ __ ] I
know where you live exactly right across
from does though looks like a straight
tattletale too you know it's like she
made a career out of tattletale if my
daddy's a professional title town
Club on the floor yesterday in love
what's the [ __ ] tattletale in Spanish
[Laughter]
in your nosy is there tattletale in like
Korean or anything [ __ ] case I
actually don't know it's just good
citizen that's why from Pennsylvania and
so she was gonna tell on you yeah she
had been chasing down a tip when this
Marshall stopped her and then here's a
video yeah how's that only go so don't
follow long if you already
yo or to her you're not mine yeah okay
Andrew alright but what exactly I
understand that you're concerned about
safety
what was that really letting Gordon I
gave you a lawful order and enforcement
officers so I actually want you men
saying you're going to your friend's
house wasn't acceptable not my friend
lives right there what is it 12 year old
some more intelligent than this guy No
[Music]
[Music]
wasn't too bad like it wasn't like he
was really harassing her it's so funny
because the voice matched the kids face
right the authority in her voice yeah
she was waiting for some type of like I
got you [ __ ] yeah just test me you know
come at me bro she was like what and why
is that illegal and how are you gonna
throw me in jail for what reason exactly
yeah and then the law is like you can't
be 300 feet or something behind a law
enforcement vehicle if they're in
pursuit of something oh okay so I think
he just forgot what the distance was but
he just knows generally hey like I can't
be following it yeah you can't be
following me right now on a bicycle
though yeah
pink helmet on chasing a lead because if
he's in pursuit of something waiting for
there's like a mountain lion in the area
that she does have to bounce right right
but I feel I also feel like he thought
he was just gonna kind of tell her to do
something and she was just gonna be like
okay I'm sorry but then she kind of gave
him you know like a little bit of a
little sass hey a little sass and then
at the end of it too you know she's
still wrong you know a lawful
enforcement opportunity hey don't follow
me she is about one of my breaking it's
like you [ __ ] annoying little kid
just bounce because it kind of feels
like that when someone says like don't
touch me I'm not touching you yeah she's
being obnoxious kids [ __ ] obnoxious
the cops told it wasn't like he was like
yeah I'm just worried about you there's
a mountain lying around or
twelve-year-old girl just get away okay
I don't know what the goddamn law is
weird of him going you could lie to your
mom your dad and your priest
you can't oh I didn't hear that word oh
no he said you can let but you can't lie
to an officer you're like okay that is
weird that's just like a saying though
that's like a saying like a like a
colloquial saying yeah yeah yeah then so
hildie was also pointing out that there
was there were other people in that area
that he didn't tell that they need to
leave so the whole mountain line thing
sounds like it was just [ __ ] oh so
it wasn't a actual threat
yeah law enforcement
said that they have dealt with the
situation and but they don't publicly
disclose personnel actions including
discipline so they didn't have any
further comfortable you probably thought
it was weird that a 12 girl was
following him on a bicycle yeah and he's
like what the [ __ ] is going on right
because hey I'm actually a reporter oh
you are right right right exactly
really give me your [ __ ] lunch money
[ __ ] out here you're going to jail I
keep hoping I think this is a [ __ ] 12
unit if she's out there trying to do her
job though that is also kind of [ __ ]
up yeah instead of selling girl-scout
cookies this girl's [ __ ] doing [ __ ]
you know Bretton to arrest her and throw
her into juvie and stuff he should have
you know he could have had a different
he he could have had a different tone
with her too
before the camera was on her sure as
soon as you notice like probably change
but uh but yeah so more about the he
goes oh you can record me but just to
let you know dumbass why'd you say that
be so so stupid
the officer oh yeah so Hildy um she's
been in the news before because she has
this like Scholastic book series called
Hildy cracks the case it's like ghost
it's like [ __ ] Saint Harriet the Spy
yeah well why don't you do the role art
no they they had an illustrator I was
like Danny's girl was a [ __ ] artist a
storyteller
never and her dad she sells these books
yeah it's a series it's like
scholasticism a guy's publisher why she
still [ __ ] trying to report [ __ ]
she's passionate sell unless she's
buying that just looks like a balan see
I want to buy that
but she needs to keep working cuz that's
her stories she's like what's next on
the case yeah she's like mini Carmen
Sandiego yes the book order of papers we
see you at school we still get them why
is it get them they still got that's
[ __ ] tongue wax paper yeah they don't
pass it on an iPad now and all the kids
just pick what they want
no cuz the parents have to order it you
just email a newsletters BAM all the
[ __ ] teachers now no they do have a
thing online whoa where those papers it
gives you a special code that's for your
school and for kids classroom and so
when I want to order books for Isaac
then I go online and then I put in a
little code and then they'll deliver it
to him do they still got the Berenstain
Bears on there how about Ghost Rider
though baby-sitters club
I didn't study the whole I never got the
books I just always wanted the [ __ ]
crystal growing thing or like some kind
of yeah activity thing the microscope
huh
every time I look at the book I'm more
like too many letters that was already
fifth grade this app it's for kids to
see like you sign up to this this
membership and there's all these kid
books that you could see on this app so
then I just ended up doing that for
Isaac instead because I knew there was a
app or new technology physical book is
really great for campfires later on no
but I just I just love looking through
it like my parents never bought it for
me but I'll look it is good think like
that oh I would want this and I would
want this one the book what do you mean
did you have books at home that you
would just like looking through you're
talking about oh no some damn paper yeah
yeah
I would [ __ ] window shop I like yeah
I wouldn't want this one oh he'll be
crash the case here dog I'm gonna buy
that book and throw in the garbage game
hey speaking of the Bears she win you
she got your money no she didn't
hi wigs I threw it in the garbage can
I'm a [ __ ] you're on dude
real quick though speaking of Berenstein
bears what was your guys's stance on
that was it barons do you guys remember
it as Berenstein or Berenstain remember
yes I thought everyone called it
Bernstein
I saw that
dilemma on the thing yeah because I
thought it was spelled E with the e but
then they say it no it was solely
spelled with the 8 and then there's like
a split of people who remember as
Berenstein and people who say Berenstain
I don't even remember what it's read
like I just remember what heard like
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]